olá a todos boa tarde a mano o meia
lucas a vu é o povo eu fiz o meu
pós-doutorado no cs que cento de
componentes e semicondutores
acho que poucas pessoas conhecem porque
são ocos centros independentes que são
diretamente ligados à reitoria
esse é um dos centros que é de exatas
a gente faz micro e nanofabricação e eu
fiz o meu pós-doutorado desde 2010 até
três meses atrás quando foi a empregada
como pesquisadora então acionou a
pesquisadora de lado o centro
o centro é praticamente só é fabricação
de micro e nano dispositivos é tudo
aplicado temos até cursos para quem está
interessado pode entrar no site para ver
porque tem prestado na parte publicação
está ea agora vou mostrar sua parte do
meu trabalho e claro do dos trabalhos
que estão integrados junto com concreto
desenvolvendo lá então a minha parte é a
minha mais para a parte instrumentação é
que a publicação como eu já falei é por
exemplo essa câmera pequena que tem 100
mil litros é usada como câmera de testes
sensoriais de gás junto a um sistema de
vácuo é você consegue testar diferentes
dispositivos e sensores de gás em
ultravioleta é e assim por diante
como várias palestras aqui falaram
bastante sobre consumo consciente
consumo consciente de energia
a gente também por nosso lado também
estão vindo para o mesmo tipo de de
idéias ea gente diminuir cada vez mais o
consumo energético junto com a
diminuição de tamanho claro então eu
simplesmente pra tentei fazer uma uma
palestra mais a mais de imagem - mas é
mais difícil pra mim essa coisa então se
no sistema de posição é muito fácil e
simplesmente a quem escala nanométrica
olha que são 10 mícrons de escala aqui
então essa parte só 200 nanômetros 100
nanômetros e tudo escala nano uma
simples de posição por de eletroforese e
diferentes tratamentos térmicos que a
gente aplica localmente para poder ter
esse tipo de resposta
seletividade e e sensibilidade um certo
tempo tipo de gasto desculpa certo
então o que eu quero implementar agora
no cs é uma técnica que esta usada aqui
no brasil que é uma ablação a laser
técnica de ablação a laser remoção de
material com a ajuda do laser ele a
posição do mesmo sobre diferentes
substratos a áreas né
um sistema um esquema simples de como
foi planejado e como vai montar esse
sistema
um detalhe eu gosto de montar os
próprios equipamentos acho mais fácil de
comprar mas fica mais lógica e mais
fácil de usar depois certo
e aqui só mostrando diferentes tipos de
materiais que você podem ser depositados
usar essa técnica em forma de filmes
finos com vocês podem ver aqui na
esquerda diferentes camadas em cima de
substratos nesse caso de silício
diferentes morfologia do mesmo material
no caso desses três material de
pirâmides views e retrô estruturas certo
um outro uma outra aplicação da técnica
que a gente tá pensando implementar é
por exemplo escrita diretamente dizer
então você pega e vai fazer um padrão um
da tam em qualquer material em qualquer
substrato e qualquer desenho que seja
estamos a andar e blu ray tem uma
técnica muito usada ultimamente para
essa parte de micro e nanofabricação
aqui nesta casa é um filme de nanotubos
de carbono
com esses dois eletrodos certo que vai
ser usado futuramente para construir um
sensor de ultra violento
e uma outra linha de pesquisa que muito
agora nos traz de carbono
nós trabalhamos com nanofitas comerciais
é ea ordem posição de cima dessas
nanofitas em diferentes substratos em
cama informa de camadas finas ou grossas
pra a aplicação de diferentes sensores
certo é por exemplo aqui um sensor de
deformação mecânica
então é podem ser usado como sensor de
pressão ou sensores de deformação
mecânico mesmo então aqui como vocês
estão vendo quando ela estará fechado
ele fez um circuito então aquela luzinha
azul não sei se vocês estão levando
então a l com 2 ao ser deformado l
interrompe circuito então pára de passar
a corrente então em função dessa mudança
na existência flash corrente do filme
você consegue controlar e verá a
sensibilidade desse material para
diferentes informações mecânicas certo
e aqui uma aplicação que é extremamente
atual né
é essa parte de fitness é todo mundo
agora é a vamos molhar
todo mundo tem que entrar na academia
mas sentar na academia não fez o exame
físico ainda não sabe muito bem está bem
aí da taquicardia aí tudo problemático é
que aconteceu apareceu um monte de novos
dispositivos de vão monitorar velho está
bem de saúde se ele tem bastantes a issa
coração dele funcionou bem e as
apareceram o esc frango leite voices
não sei se vocês ouviram acho que é
muito aqueles que simplesmente se cola
na sua pele e tenta monitorar algumas
partes do organismo que seja pele
coração pulmão alguma coisa nós estamos
indo pra esse lado exatamente aqueles
firmes de nanofitas de grafeno que vocês
viram em dever e no substrato só voltar
um pouco o que é interessante essa
que que é um firme é condutor semi
transparente e flexível é super
interessante e é pega é momento que você
colocar esse elastômero na sua pele como
chama se segue a sua o formato do corpo
direitinho cola que nem uma beleza né
então a gente fez testes por exemplo de
batimentos cardíacos antes e depois do
do exercício físico no homem de 30 e
poucos anos 40 anos
como vocês podem ver tem uma mudança
tanto no final como no formato do pico
então é uma aplicação que a gente está
tendo agora em vista que está a estudar
bastante a pesquisa inicial né
mas a além dessas há dispositivos que eu
apresentei
temos também parte de off mm filho até
trânsito desculpa mês é que a minha boca
a parte de caracterização ea fabricação
por baterem por outros métodos lá no
centro de componentes como
semicondutores quem está interessado
podem fazer uma visita é um centro
aberto multidisciplinar de que a vontade
nos contatar tá bom
muito obrigado a todos uma boa tarde